étant moi-même l'habitué des endroits ça
lag de tout parent et quelle ne fut pas
ma surprise lorsque le feu mes amis et
moi littéralement refoulé à l'entrée de
cet établissement par un paltoquet
manquant cruellement de physionomie de
savoir-vivre
rapport au savoir vivre des minions tu
wirth et écrase mère de mon but à l'img
vite platine
[Applaudissements]
ça va
je ne sais pas dit de rentrer
sortez c'est loupé
ça s'est produit vers où là on
recommence on met tait ou latin la
maison de pain je recommence voilà on
recommence allez-y bonsoir ça va bonsoir
nous sommes deux oui très bien c'est
pourquoi en avoir activé r&b s'est
apprécié à d'accord comme ça maintenant
cette première fois qu'on joue
effectivement c'est vrai c'est vrai je
me fais le vin sans chanter chanter ici
je suis à voir ce qu'on appelle habitués
de la boîte je viens comme tous les
soirs je me réjouis faites la vente
maintenant non non je ne suis pas j'ai
pas un chien je suis un bon client de me
tuer je reviens ce n'est pas pour vous
enfermer ses chats bon client si un
petit peu là quand même commencer un
petit peu j'ai rendez vous avec là
qu'est toute la clique
et autrement fait happer olivier
autrement ma mère travaillait canal coco
pas me faire rentrer jeu
il y en a d'autres bon alors c'est quoi
numéros aussi appelés tous et pas suivi
c'est pas moi je travaille pas ici moi
pas d'accord
passé là bas oui mais
voilà au lieu de marcher c'est pas
possible à ce soir monsieur tu prends
ton nom on est plein là on a chez notre
notre quota de blé au un peu plus on va
merci ça veut dire qu est ce qu on a un
quota de blé rose et oui à l'accord dont
vous prenez pour les maisons
la première vue
d'accord avec toi t'es quoi tu comprends
quoi la dernière fois c'était alors moi
je veux buzz en tout cas bien au chaud
physionomiste fait pipi contre le bar
moi
c'est que je suis bon je me souviens
très bien m'a demandé est périmé en plus
votre
pompiste manière cette carte est là elle
marche que
vous faites ça ça va pas aller vous êtes
quand
vous êtes tout seul oui
d'accord alors allez-y
[Musique]